devant l'entrée de l'université de
Kaboul ces étudiantes se butent à des
porte-closes des talibans armés leur
bloque le passage
qu'on avait plus le droit d'aller à
l'école cette étudiant
en nous privant du droit d'être éduqué
c'est comme si tu es notre avenir
ajoutez
devant l'université de Jalalabad dans
l'est du pays des étudiants hommes et
femmes encourageusement pris par une
manifestation pour dénoncer ce nouveau
recul du droit des femmes depuis le
retour au pouvoir des talibans il y a un
peu plus d'un an déjà en mars dernier
les filles s'étaient vu privées
d'éducation secondaire et depuis les
femmes sont peu à peu effacées de la
sphère publique
au développement du pays ils veulent que
nous restions à la maison pour faire des
enfants soutien cette étudiante afghane
les États-Unis ont dénoncé une décision
qu'il qualifie de barbares
cette décision inacceptable aura des
conséquences pour les talibans menacent
pour te parler américain
le respect des droits de la personne est
particulièrement des droits des femmes
est en effet une condition essentielle à
l'aide humanitaire et financière dont un
désespérément besoin
l'afghanistanale doit intervenir et
pleure cette jeune femme étudiée et ma
seule passion comme des centaines
d'autres étudiantes elle n'a pour
l'instant d'autre choix que de refermer
ses livres et espérer un miracle ici
lise Villeneuve Radio-Canada Montréal